le 11 août 2020 alors que l'humanité se
débattait en pleine pandémie la russie a
pris tout le monde de court en annonçant
l'homologation du premier vaccin contre
le coc u19 si oignons
ce matin pour la première fois au monde
à vaccins contre le nouveau coronavirus
a été enregistré
je sais qu'il est assez efficace qu'il
donne une immunité durable je le répète
il a passé tous les tests nécessaires
accusé d'avoir été lancé dans la
précipitation et avec un manque de
transparence le vaccin ce boutique v est
accueilli avec scepticisme à l'étranger
nos homologues étrangers qui semble-t-il
ressentent une certaine rivalité et
voient les avantages du vaccin russe
temps d'exprimer des opinions qui selon
nous sont complètement infondées
jusqu'à la publication d'un article de
la prestigieuse revue médicale
britannique de 27 qui estime que le
candidat vaccin déclencher une réponse
immunitaire et n'entraîne pas d'effets
indésirables graves
la même revue qui a annoncé un peu plus
tard une efficacité de 91,6 % contre les
formes symptomatiques ducobu 19 de quoi
faire changer d'opinion bon nombre de
personnes en effet beaucoup de pays
commencent alors à s'intéresser de près
aux vaccins russe qui au passage est
meilleur marché et plus faciles à
conserver que ses concurrents la russie
en parlait de la vaccination de sa
propre population commence à exporter
des doses de spoutnik à travers le monde
argentine algérie mexique sont parmi les
premiers acquéreurs un an après son
lancement le vaccin est autorisé dans 69
pays représentant une population totale
de 3 7 milliards de personnes des
accords de coopération permettent en
outre sa fabrication dans 14 pays
d'autant que le vaccin se montre tout
aussi efficace également contre les
variants ducobu 19 responsables de
nouvelles flambées épidémiques
ces derniers mois
comme le montre l'expérience de la mise
en circulation pour la population le
vaccin est complètement sûr et hautement
efficaces
il est efficace non seulement face aux
variants contre lesquels il a été créé
mais aussi contre les nombreux variant
qui sont apparus au cours de ces
derniers temps et qui nous attaquent
constamment j'espère que le vaccin sera
tout aussi efficace à l'avenir et qu'il
protégera bien notre population ainsi
que les populations des pays qui ont
décidé d'utiliser ce médicament
mais voilà russie oblige le sujet de la
vaccination est rapidement devenue
politique insiste poutine mais doit être
validée par l' agence européenne des
médicaments afin de se voir ouvrir le
marché européen début mars le dossier
déposé mais depuis toujours pas nouvelle
et du côté du gouvernement français on
est particulièrement réticent face au
vaccin russe à la manière dont ces gérer
c'est plus un moyen de propagande et de
diplomatie agressive qu'un moyen de
solidarité et dead sanitaires il y à
certains pays comme l'espagne qui était
hantée où qu'ils ont fait à un moment la
reconnaissance de certains vaccins comme
le russe ou le chinois nous on dit aux
partenaires européens on leur a dit
encore ces derniers jours attention et
non pour ses vaccins certains dirigeants
au sein de l'union européenne se montre
on ne peut plus pessimistes et il va
chino rouge pour l'on constate que scout
nick n'a pas encore été approuvé par le
m&a et ne le sera peut être jamais les
mains pourtant à l'intérieur même de
l'europe d'autres pays ont fait le choix
du vaccin russe c'est le cas de la
hongrie et de la slovaquie mais aussi de
saint marin dont la population a
majoritairement été vaccinés avec scout
élevé
selon nos données le vaccin offre une
efficacité élevée à l'est proche de 100
% grâce à la vaccination spoutnik vais
tous les habitants de saint marin ont
développé des anticorps
et depuis le 4 août dernier les
certificats de vaccination spots xv et
de saint marin sont désormais reconnus
dans l'union européenne peut-être un
premier pas vers sa reconnaissance en
attendant la pandémie est encore loin
d'être terminée et la vaccination est à
ce jour la stratégie la plus efficace
pour la combattre et un an après son
lancement spoutnik v continue à prouver
qu'il est une arme de choix dans cette
bataille